this video was made possible by
curiosity stream
watch the companion video to this one
and loads more exclusive content
by signing up for the curiosity stream
nebula bundle deal at
curiositystream.com
wendover the story of supersonic
passenger travel
is long and tumultuous nearly everyone
has heard some version
of why concord failed it was certainly
the epitome of a technology ahead of its
time but the true story of why it failed
or rather more accurately
why it retired is more nuanced than the
popular narrative
of an overzealous overly extravagant
inflexible aircraft
there are degrees to which that
narrative is true but what you don't
often hear
is this concorde was profitable
a 747 the flagship of any subsonic fleet
during the reign of concord
required a gallon of fuel to carry one
passenger 80 miles
or 1 liter for 34 kilometers assuming a
full load
meanwhile concorde required roughly one
gallon to carry one passenger
17 miles or one liter per seven
kilometers
clearly a quite decisive difference
concord was vastly less efficient than
the aircraft that is today fading away
due to its inefficiency but the story
doesn't
end there jet fuel currently costs about
1.68 cents per gallon
therefore the fuel bill on a new york to
london 747 flights per passenger
is about 73 and a half dollars not a
dramatic amount
relative to ticket prices similarly
concord burning about 206 gallons or 780
liters of jet fuel to carry a passenger
across the atlantic
would burn 346 dollars in fuel
that's a staggeringly small number
compared to its inflation-adjusted
ticket price of roughly 16
000 round trip both air france
and british airways the two operators of
the aircraft
paid a small sum for the aircraft
relative to its multi-billion dollar
development cost
bankrolled by the french and british
governments maintenance and operational
costs were certainly high
but certainly not at the level that some
autopsies of the aircraft's demise make
them out to be
so altogether both airlines were able to
turn
a tidy profit across the aircraft's
three decades of supersonic service
but there were other issues
part of it was versatility with a meager
4 500 mile
7 200 kilometer range and a brutally
loud sonic boom that forced nearly every
government to ban it from flying over
the speed of sound over land
there were very very few routes on which
the aircraft could be used effectively
compounding those issues its seats were
sold slightly above first class prices
around 16 000 round trip inflation
adjusted
and there are very very few routes that
can sustain that level of first class
capacity
between eos slavial max jet silver jet
british airways and others
there's a long history of airlines
attempting to operate all business class
flights between london or paris and new
york
and yet every single one of these
eventually
failed concord essentially involved
trying to operate
all first-class flights for context
in a non-coveted impacted schedule
british airways flies a mere 98
first-class seats between london and new
york each day
with concord's double daily new york
schedule british airways was operating
some 200 first class seats in addition
to dozens more on their regular
subsonic services that's an enormous
amount of first class capacity that this
route
the most valuable in the world can't
even support today
so it's no surprise that it couldn't
decades ago
therefore many concord services operated
with more seats empty than full
and yet british airways still turned a
profit
their typical 50 to 60 load factor
worked great from a financial
perspective
and some back of the napkin math
estimates that they could have broken
even
with as little as a 35 load factor
in fact it's possible that they stumbled
into the right sail strategy
the one they had been missing all along
in the aircraft's
final days after it was announced that
concord would be retired
but while it was still flying british
airways heavily discounted fares
closer to business class pricing which
increased load factors dramatically
and yet they turned a 70 million
dollar profit more than they ever
had before but many believe that british
airways and air france
weren't seriously trying to make money
with the aircraft
in the end its end came as the result of
decades of lesser issues
colliding with pure bad luck
while taking off from charles de gaulle
airport on july 25th 2000
air france concord fbtsc ran over a
piece of engine cowling that a previous
departure had lost
blew a tire and the ensuing debris
ruptured a fuel tank
spilling fuel that ignited within
seconds
113 lives perished
this greatly sullied the image of the
aircraft that both airlines had been
using primarily as a marketing tool
rather than a true profit center
maintenance bills were mounting as
concord
aged and there were some indications
that first class services on subsonic
british airways and air france planes
were turning a higher profit assuming
that was true
these airlines would rather have had
their passengers fly their subsonic
services
an assertion backed up by the fact that
both airlines refused to sell
rather than retire concorde worrying
that that would lead to losing loyal
concord flyers entirely
rather than converting them to subsonic
services
altogether the time was right to sunset
the world's first supersonic passenger
plane two decades have now passed
with all the progress the world has made
in its march through time
some could not accept a new era bound by
mere subsonic travel we're now
approaching
a possible renaissance of supersonic
passenger planes
and this time it might actually
work there are three key players in the
race to bring back supersonic travel
none of which are airbus boeing embraer
or
any other current aircraft manufacturer
arion was founded in 2003
the same year's concord's retirement and
has spent the decades since developing
a supersonic private jet the as2
in the time scale of aircraft
development they're not too far
from launch with production expected to
start in 2023
and a possible launch by 2026 boasting
financial backing from boeing and a
partnership with ge for engine
development
arion is certainly not in the business
of selling
pipe dreams operating with a similar
business strategy
spike aerospace also aims to develop a
smaller supersonic private
jet uniquely they're planning to reduce
complexity and increase efficiency
by eliminating windows entirely in the
passenger cabin
replacing them with screens displaying
high definition camera feeds from
outside
despite its lack of big-name partners
and a less slick public appearance
spike is viewed as a real contender and
is working on a similar time scale to
arium
then there's boom technologies
if you've heard of any supersonic
aircraft developer
this is the one their business model
is entirely different they're not taking
the conservative
safer route with smaller private jets
they
want the whole pie they want to be
concord 2.0 after emerging
from the same powerhouse silicon valley
accelerator program responsible for
airbnb
doordash reddit and more they've
initially focused their time
and funding on developing a one-person
proof-of-concept supersonic
jet the xb1 to serve their ultimate goal
of launching
a 65 to 88 passenger commercial
supersonic
jet the overture like arion
they have some serious partners japan
airlines the us air force
rolls royce and more and are viewed as
the most
ambitious of the three companies yet
potentially the one
with the most attainable goal
now supersonic passenger travel has
already
existed even if it doesn't now
it will not be a technological
breakthrough to simply make that happen
again what will be a breakthrough if
achieved though
is doing what concord could not
concord could not facilitate widespread
supersonic travel
in a sustainable manner both
economically and
environmentally these companies just
might a good portion of concord's issues
originated from noise you see a sonic
boom
is not as some incorrectly believe an
isolated burst of noise at the moment a
plane reaches the speed of sound
from the ground it is perceived as an
isolated burst of sound
since a plane and therefore shock waves
are moving
but a sonic boom originates continuously
as any object travels above the speed of
sound
therefore if concord were to fly from
new york to los angeles
at supersonic speeds everyone between
the cities would hear
the 110 decibel noise that's roughly
equivalent to the loudness of a chainsaw
in your own hands
so it's no wonder why nearly every
country in the world
banned supersonic planes over land
many believe that to make supersonic
passenger aviation viable
these bans need to end gaining the
political will to allow
a small number of incredibly wealthy
people in supersonic jets to create
such noise pollution is unrealistic so
rather
quite a lot of work is being put into
turning the sonic boom
into more of a sonic thump while there
are a few different techniques being
tested
nasa is leading one of the most
concerted efforts to create a
low boom supersonic plane they
contracted lockheed martin to develop
the x-59 as part of their low boom
flight demonstrator program
and if successful it will turn the
perceived loudness of a sonic boom
from that of a chainsaw to a car door
closing you see with concord or
essentially any existing supersonic
plane
someone on the ground or more accurately
the ocean would actually hear
two booms in very rapid succession
that's because
the shock waves that are perceived as
sonic booms originate almost
entirely from the nose and tail of the
aircraft
they coalesce together and travel to the
ground leading to those
two rapid booms the theory behind nasa's
x-59 aircraft
is to spread those shock waves out to
create a longer
but quieter sonic boom with an elongated
skinny shape
and strategically placed canards smaller
shockwaves originate across the length
of the aircraft
thereby spreading the impact out after
taking its first flight in 2022
this aircraft will be deployed from 2023
to 2025
to conduct tests over certain towns and
cities
they'll then gather feedback from those
on the ground essentially asking if the
sound is tolerable
before bringing their findings to
national regulators around the world
with the goal of creating
a new standard for an acceptable sonic
boom in 2025
arion and spike have quite a lot
riding on that 2025 decision they're
both basing their business
around the prospect of enabling
supersonic travel not only over oceans
but over continents too therefore
while their methods differ from nasa's
both companies are selling their
aircraft
off of the promise of quiet sonic booms
boom technologies though with their
overture commercial jet
is taking a different tack when looking
at boom's marketing materials
all the potential routes mentioned are
transoceanic
and that's no mistake they're not
risking anything
on the potential of governments changing
a decades-old
rule they're building a jet that's going
to have a sonic boom
that's going to be loud and that's going
to have little immediate prospect of
flying over
land and they're fine with that they're
essentially building a jet that will be
almost
exclusively used on transatlantic and
trans-pacific routes
which do represent a big chunk of the
world's long-haul flights
and unless there's a massive change in
legislation it just won't be useful for
say europe to asia flights boom
certainly does have legislative hurdles
their aircraft will be louder at takeoff
than current noise restrictions allow
but this is part of the reason why the
company with the most ambitious goal
might actually have one of the better
chances
at success but success for any of these
companies
and passenger supersonic travel as a
whole all
hinges on the business case what brought
concord
down was at a fundamental level
economics
even if it did attain profitability for
the airlines
if anything the attractiveness of
supersonic passenger travel
has declined since the days of concord
when it first entered service the
highest class of service on most
airlines
offered seats similar to that of
international premium economy today
nowadays every major transatlantic
airline has business class seats that
lie
flat as beds offering travelers the
opportunity to get a decent night's rest
while essentially losing no productive
time by flying overnight
in addition the vast majority of
concord's passengers were traveling
on business a segment of traveler for
which time efficiency
is paramount in 1970 or 80 or 90
any time spent on a plane simply could
not be productive
for business nowadays though most major
airlines offer wi-fi
and people can conduct much of their
work remotely meaning someone on a
7-hour transatlantic flight
can if they want get close to seven
hours of work
done even if travel is now less time
efficient
it can be more productive therefore
with supersonic travel theoretically
less attractive
arion spike and boom need to take the
flawed business model of concord
and improve upon it enough to not only
fix concourse issues
but address the new more challenging
business
environment of course they know that
so that's exactly what they're doing
arion and spike focusing first and
foremost on private jets
sees this market as a more attainable
target
arion for example is planning on a 120
million dollar list price for its jet
while this is
quite the tidy sum there are people
buying 120 million dollar private jets
today for example airbus has sold more
than 100 a320 family aircraft as private
jets
and those also list for upwards of 100
million
dollars there are also plenty of private
737s a330s
757s a340 747s
and more with thousands of billionaires
globally
there are certainly plenty of people who
can and will
pay for the prestige and convenience of
a supersonic private jet
in addition to the lowered price
sensitivity the private jet market has
another advantage its consumers
inherently value time
incredibly highly on long-haul trips
most private jets are objectively less
comfortable than certain first-class
options on commercial airlines most
mid-range private jets
have eight to twelve seats roughly
equivalent in shape and size to those
used as first class on u.s domestic
flights
a large recliner seat in addition to a
couch which sometimes converts into a
single bed for the primary traveler
if you were to fly from hong kong to
sydney for example
a group of wealthy people could take
singapore airlines's fully enclosed
suites
with dedicated beds for each person for
a fraction of the cost of a jet
but what they lose is time convenience
and prestige
considering that plenty of people still
choose to fly private long haul
the type of person accustomed to flying
private values
time convenience and prestige first and
foremost
above comfort and that's exactly the
market that supersonic private jets
appeal to
arion sees enough demand for 500 to 600
of their aircraft in the next 20 years
and if they're right they're well on
their way
to profitability boom technologies
meanwhile
has to confront the task of making
supersonic work
for commercial airlines this time
it's not going to be all about prestige
airlines are
not going to get aircraft for a fraction
of development costs
and they're going to have to fly on more
than the few highest yield routes in the
world
their strategy has been essentially to
trade
a marketing problem for a development
problem
they claim that their aircraft will
enable airlines to charge fares
similar to that of business class as
opposed to the first class fares that
were charged for concorde
of course remember in concord's final
six months of operation for british
airways
they charged lower fares closer to
business class prices
and that correlated with the most
profitable six months in the aircraft's
history now if boom creates an aircraft
with low enough purchase fueling and
maintenance costs to enable such
business class fares
it's hard to believe that airlines won't
find routes on which
it'll work for now we'll just have to
take their word for it
and wait and see there's hardly any way
now a decade from overture's earliest
possible service entry
to know if this is realistic the
fundamental advantage that this new
generation of supersonic passenger jets
has
is that it's a new generation
a second generation concorde's
development program
financed by the french and british
governments was a massively expensive
deeply unprofitable venture the true
beneficiaries of that spending though
are arion spike boom and
every other company that will develop
supersonic jets
with the benefit of hindsight they get
to develop a jet that addresses
concord shortcomings which objectively
means that they have
more opportunity for success that's
certainly not to say
they will succeed they each have to stay
afloat throughout a long
challenging and risky development
process but they are closer to the
finish line
than anyone has ever been before
whether the world needs or wants
supersonic planes is an entirely
different question
but regardless it seems more certain
than ever
that within a generation the world will
once again
become a far smaller place
i myself of course never flew concord so
i was curious what it was like
i know the broad strokes but i wanted
the nitty
details what was the concord experience
like in the airport which lounge did
they use what was the meal like on board
what did people do on board what was it
like to land in new york before taking
off from london
at least on the clock so i did a bunch
of research
compiled it into a companion video to
this one and uploaded that
to nebula of course the reason why it's
there is because the youtube algorithm
actually punishes us creators for trying
something new but nebula is a different
platform
with no algorithm no ads no data mining
it's a video platform that is just about
great unique content
made by great independent educational
creators
the ecosystem and its financial model
allows us to take risks and make big
budget projects like alaska's silent
summer
my brand new hour-long documentary shot
on location in ketchikan
a tourist town in alaska that suddenly
had to confront a reality
without tourists the best way to get
nebula
is undoubtedly through the rather
amazing curiosity stream bundle deal
at current sale prices it's less than 15
a
year to get access to both sites
curiosity stream has some phenomenal
stuff too
one of my favorites is gander
international the airport in the middle
of nowhere
about the airport that used to be one of
the most important in the world as a
refueling point between the us and
europe
until planes got longer range i truly
don't know of a better deal in streaming
two streaming sites with stuff you'll
actually watch for less than fifteen
dollars
a year at current sale pricing what's
more
signing up actually helps support
countless independent creators
so make sure to do so at com
curiositystream.com
wendover